it's time for another challenge charlie
hi
so last week I confessed my love of
Doctor Who unto the world and as a
result of that I received quite a few
Doctor Who related challenges my
favorite doctor who related challenge
was submitted by this person who
suggested trying some fish custards
which for the uninitiated is probably
what you think it is it's a combination
of custard and fish fingers sounds
disgusting right yeah first off I'm
going to cook my fish fingers that thing
that you can hear is the sound of the
oven heating up because I forgot to
preheat it because I'm an idiot
I'm worried about two possibilities one
that it's gonna taste absolutely
horrible but I'm also worried about the
prospect of me actually enjoying it I
can't really imagine how it's gonna
taste so it could be delicious I don't
know I guess we'll just have to wait and
see I've decided not to heat up the
custard I'm figuring out to try and
treat it like ketchup plus a light cold
custard but do I like cold custard with
fish fingers that's the question I
couldn't work out what I thought it
would taste like before but now it's
pretty obvious that it tastes like fish
fingers and custard the worst part is
that it's kind of tasty it's not
massively tasty I mean they're not
really built to go together but as a
hungry person who hasn't had any lunch
yet and who has fish fingers and custard
here I mean notice ain't no second fish
finger here if you're a fan of Doctor
Who right maybe have a gala with it
that's all I'm saying
especially if you're a big Doctor Who
fan I mean you can't you can't be a
Doctor Who fan without try and fish
gusted mmm okay it starts tasting a bit
weird around the end of the second fifth
finger it's like having a dessert in a
main course at the same time so while
I'm here eating the fish custard two
things I want to tell you about first
lots of people ask me do I like Matt
Smith yes I like Matt Smith I don't
really wanna make a final judgment on
him until I've seen the whole of his
first series but yeah I really like him
sorry anyone who isn't interested in
Doctor Who I promise to make the next
video strictly non who related second
I've recently tried to do something that
I've always want
to do since I was like eight which is
design t-shirts Oh charlie stupid sell
out sell your t-shirts let just sell out
you stupid sell out face well I agree
with you I don't really like it when I
see you tubers selling t-shirts just for
the sake of it without really putting
much thought into it so I decided to
draw the design myself and make
something that I was you know genuinely
proud of because if I wasn't proud of it
I wouldn't want to share it with you
okay I I think I've reached my cutoff
point with fish custard now it's just
gonna be a limited run and so I'll put
an annotation here either telling you
when the cutoff point for orders will be
or telling you that the orders have now
stopped if you're interested in getting
one then go to Charlie McDonnell come
forward slash shop and if you're not
interested in getting one and you don't
have to that is the end of the video
good bye you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool